-Welcome back to "Late Night."
Now I'm sure everyone here
is familiar with the McRib,
the sandwich from McDonald's
with an almost cult-like status,
that shows up out of the blue
and sticks around
for a couple of months or so
before disappearing again.
Well, for the past 30 years,
comedy writers have been writing
about the McRib
every single time it comes back,
each time, each comedy writer,
acting like they were the first
to observe the strangeness
of a seasonal sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
Well, one of my writers came to
me with a McRib idea and said,
"I think I have a fresh take."
And I said, "I doubt that."
[ Laughter ]
"But let's hear it."
And then he told me.
And I think he actually
did find a fresh take.
Well, here he is,
my writer Ben Warheit.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Hi, McRib.
It's me, your son.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I heard you might be
coming back soon.
[ Laughter ]
Listen, I -- I don't want
to fight with you.
I just want to say,
you can't keep
walking into and out
of our lives anymore.
[ Laughter ]
Showing up unannounced,
"Hey, everybody, surprise!
The McRib is back!"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, surprise.
You know, there was a time
I would have given anything
just to be near you?
I'd skip school,
blow off my friends,
I'd come looking for you.
You'd already be gone.
[ Laughter ]
And I don't even know when
you're planning to come back.
I mean, sure, the Shamrock Shake
leaves his kids all the time.
[ Laughter ]
But at least they know
when his bright-green ass
is gonna come home.
[ Laughter ]
-Right? I mean, we've never
seen this take before.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I gotta say...
I think the acting is,
uh, pretty good, too.
Let's -- Let's go back.
♪♪
-You know what, McRib?
I'm grown.
I can deal with it.
But Emma, your daughter,
you missed her prom.
And mom...
she can't even show her face
at a Fourth of July barbecue.
But you don't care, do you?
No, 'cause you only do
what you wanna do,
show up in town,
out of the blue.
Make a quick buck,
and spend time with people
who, let's be honest,
they're not your friends,
they're [bleep] fans.
[ Laughter ]
They're just gonna chew you up
and [bleep] you out --
quickly!
Faster than most foods.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
You know what you are?
You -- You're sad.
You're a sad old man
just chasing your glory days.
You don't love your family,
because how can you
love anything
when you don't love yourself?
So, next time you think you just
want to drop in unannounced,
do us all a big favor --
stay away.
'Cause we don't want you here.
And if you think for a second --
-Uh, Ben, I'm sorry.
Wait.
I'm -- I'm getting a message
from the McRib right now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah?
-He says he's coming back.
-Papa's coming home!
Whoo-hoo!
Oh, I -- I gotta go
to the balloon store!
Band -- Band,
play some fanfare!
Play some good music!
♪♪
I gotta go!
Bye!
♪♪
-Now, I told you that was
a fresh take, and I --
I stand by that.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't say "good take."
But we takes
the takes we can get.